and you tell me just a little bit about
your childhood sure I was born in 1948
in Bayonne New Jersey which is a
blue-collar industrial town my father
was a longshoreman we never had much
money so we never went anywhere we did
not even own a car I lived in a world
that was five blocks long my school was
on Fifth Street
I lived on First Street from the
projects where I lived I could see these
huge tankers flying all the flags of the
world
I had a big book of flags that I would
look at that watch the ships go by and
wonder what countries they came from and
I'd look up and say oh that one's from
Norway and that one's from South Africa
or whatever and dream about being on
those ships and then I found books and
in books I could go to Mars
I could go to King Arthur's Court I
could hunt through Sherwood Forest with
Robin Hood I could fight Martians being
with HG Wells and you know it opened
worlds for me enabled me to live life
and I think that's what fantasy does
[Music]
I've always made up stories I found
notebooks that I had since I was a kid
where I'm writing you know I can't be
more than five or six I'm drawing
pictures of the planets and writing Mars
and then descriptions of all the people
who live on Mars and and made-up planets
you know I didn't know the distinction
between Mars on one hand and Zumba on
the other so from the age of five it was
fantasy fiction fantasy science fiction
and horror which I called monster
stories
who in the literary world were you
influenced by all simply in off when I
was quite young my bigfooter influence
was comic books okay I mean I read all
the comic books of the time Superman and
Batman and the superhero comics were my
favorites age 60 you pulled off an
amazing coup and had a letter in Marvel
I had a number of letters in Marvel the
first one was in Fantastic Four and it
was about Stan Lee and was better than
Shakespeare Marvel published all my
letters but it led to stuff because in
those days when they printed your letter
they printed your full address
underneath it so other comic book fans
began to send me letters and they began
to send me fanzines and a lot of them
were produced by high school kids which
is what I was at the time and I started
subscribing to some and then I started
writing for some I wrote some articles
some critical articles saying about what
comics I liked and what I didn't like
and what was wrong with the bad ones and
then I started writing some fiction
because they also published fiction and
that was the big breakthrough how did it
feel it felt great other people started
sending in letters saying how much they
liked it yeah you know the ego boo as
they called it ego boosting that made me
feel tremendous